one of the things we also have to um
acknowledge is that while yes some of
the people uh a recent uh newcomers uh
who came illegally through the open
border we have on the south coast where
we allow small boats uh to come in a lot
of uh particularly the more the most
extreme islamists in this country uh
haven't come in recent years they're
people who are second and third
generation immigrants often well
educated often well integrated they have
jobs and and and the they participate in
society they they speak good English Etc
um so it's not just that we have let the
wrong people in it's also that we have
done a terrible job of assimilation and
integration all right Constantine we are
in your country and I was going to
dinner last night and I went by a Hamas
rally how do you feel about that was a
Hamas rally was a pro Palestine rally I
make no distinction because I don't
think they're making a distinction I
don't think anyone out there is making a
distinction but I don't think anyone out
there is uh chanting slogans against
tamas and that was clearly what ignited
it do you think that's a fair estimation
no no no I think I think we have to
distinguish I think what really troubled
me was what we saw in the first couple
of days which is Israel hadn't done
anything hadn't responded uh and people
were out there in jubilant and
celebratory that to me is clearly
support with terrorism there are lots of
people in this country who just you know
you know all this they've been
brainwashed into oppressor oppressed
they think the Palestinians are
oppressed therefore they you know it's
the the AOC you know I remember when she
first got elected and she was asked
about Israel it was clear she knew
nothing about it we've played the clip
many times yeah but she did say I'm
always on the side of the of the
oppressed and so I think there are a lot
of people in this country who are not
pro Hamas at all but they are
reflexively pro Palestine because they
keep being told that there you know the
Palestinians are oppressed etc etc so I
intellectually I understand that but
having driven past a few of them I don't
think there's any reason to think that
there's anyone there who doesn't support
Kamas I mean no one there would say I
didn't see anyone there with a sign
saying I'm for the Palestinians or the
gazin and I'm against Hamas that would
not go particularly well for them yeah I
don't think that the I I you know what I
mean I understand you're saying sort of
on paper but I think in function there's
no one there saying oh we're against
Hamas
that's the the fuel that that doesn't
necessarily mean they are for Hamas I
think I think we do have to make that
distinction I I don't think millions of
people in this country support Hamas but
but back to your question I'm not happy
that there are thousands and thousand I
said this in my speech yesterday I've
been in the dark place these last few
weeks to find out irrespective of Jews
or not or whoever just that there are
thousands of people in this country who
think uh massacring civilians as
something to be celebrated right that
should trouble us so what do you think
well since we're here in London I mean
what do you think that the British
people have to do about this it does not
strike me uh that England has a way out
of this in a weird sense well there is a
way out of it but I don't know that
there is a way out of it that they are
willing to consider um yeah I think well
ultimately it's going to mean electing
people who are going to do something
about these issues um whether that's
likely to happen as a whole different
conversation I'm not particularly
optimistic about that what what would
something well uh the example I would
give you is in the first few days after
those rallies that I talked about the
the pro hamash rallies yeah the pro
terrorism rallies uh there was polling
done um of Labor and conservative voots
in this country 92% of conservative
voters and 70% of Labor voters Which is
higher than I actually thought support
deporting people who glorify terrorism
and in this country we have different
rules around Free Speech as you know
right so glor ification of terrorism is
illegal publicly expressing support for
Hamas is illegal Etc the majority of the
country basically agrees that these
people if they're foreign Nationals
shouldn't be here there is nobody
including the current conservative
government who is going to get rid of
them so where that leaves us I think is
quite a dangerous place actually because
the people who will come along and say
we're going to do this are going to be
very very extreme uh I would much rather
the mainstream took care of this problem
do you think this could have been dealt
with maybe 8 years ago say pre- brexit
you know when there was this massive
wave of immigration had it been at least
nipped at that point perhaps it would
not be as dire as it seems now uh I
don't think so I think one of the things
we also have to um acknowledge is that
while yes some of the people uh recent
uh newcomers uh who came illegally
through the open border we have on the
south coast where we allow small boats
uh to come in a lot of uh particularly
the more the the most extreme islamists
in this country uh haven't come in
recent years they're people who are
second and third generation immigrants
often well educated often well
integrated they have jobs and and and
they participate in society they they
speak good English Etc um so it's not
just that we have let the wrong people
in it's also that we have done a
terrible job of assimilation and
integration uh you're British you're
also Jewish so I know Jewish Jewish me
however Jew you are it's enough for them
oh the anti-semites are the ones that
always determine who's Jewish this is
how when people say to me are you Jewish
I'm like well look I'm a quarter Jewish
ethnic down the father's side I don't
think I've ever been in the synagogue
I'm not practicing but if Hamas I hate
to tell you moot point if if I'm ask
hijack an airplane I'm going to be on
the list you're on the list um I mean
that was also when I right when I got
here there was that first or I guess I
don't know if it was the first but there
was this sort of M passive 100,000
person rally they said and I was
thinking man if I was a Jew that lived
in London you'd have to be going where's
my passport and and what are the options
um I'm not going to lie yeah I mean do
you think that's what the average Jew is
is feeling I you know we have it's not
just the Jews but it starts with the
Jews um we have this uh in Russia where
I I was born and where I come from
originally we have lots of Jewish jokes
made by Russian Jews to reflect the
tragedy of Jews in Eastern Europe on the
roof basically and yes and so the joke
is a bunch of Jews are sitting around
discussing something and another Jew
comes along and he says look guys I
don't know what you're talking about but
I agree it's the right time to
leave and um yeah I I I speak to a lot
of Jewish people particularly sort of
people who are openly Jewish people who
may wear the kipar people who who may be
recognizably Jewish in the street um who
are all considering and I'll be honest
with you I mean when I saw those scenes
I have to say that um I
am I am very naturally optimistic as a
human
being when I see this moment I am not
optimistic about the future and the
reason is I like to think I'm a pretty
smart guy I talk to a lot of people are
much smarter than me and I all I ask
them all the same question how is this
going to get fixed right and none of
them have an answer because the truth is
we are allowing more people to come in
who have this worldview and we're not
getting rid of the people who are
already here who we could get rid of and
we're not doing a good job of
assimilating and integrating people
whereby they buy into what it means to
be British and prod is that not is that
British people not doing a good job or
is that they've made their choice and
they don't want to integrate in that way
I mean in America we have millions of
Muslim people they have integrated we we
have deer board Michigan is a particular
problem but I mean the integration
problem is it's a two-way street right
well of course it's a two-way street but
but it is a it is a consequence of the
way that the host country act and there
are countries like Sweden and Denmark
who are taking very drastic action now
when it comes to you know breaking up
ghettos and and and taking all sorts of
other actions that in my opinion
European countries are going to have to
do unless we
want tens of thousands to become
hundreds of thousands right what do you
do in a situation where you have the
polling the way you describe it and yet
political leaders who seemingly will do
nothing I mean it seems like your prime
minister's made some good statements but
it's like no one thinks he's going to
obviously do anything yeah what do you
do about that like you have to magically
have to use alchemy to come up with a
better politics well this is why I'm not
optimistic because I don't I don't see
what the answer is I I don't see the
conservative party and it's because they
care more about Guardian headlines than
they do about doing what the people want
them to do yeah and and when that stops
I have no idea as a as a creature of the
internet what what do you make of the
social media War related to all of this
you know there's obviously the Tik Tock
portion which has been completely
overtaken by the the pro quote unquote
Palestine people but I'm noticing on
Twitter I have never gotten well it's
not even that I'm getting more hate than
ever which I pretty accustomed to
getting hate but the level of bots the
second I tweet something is completely
out of control oh really I haven't
noticed oh oh man the second I tweet
anything a gillion people who don't
follow me with the same Hitler all and
whatever whatever it's on my phone it's
yeah yeah um but what do you make of the
social media war and also how it sort of
affected young people yeah I what I see
on Twitter and I said this when Elon
first took over I was very happy and I
remained very happy and optimistic for
for for Twitter because I think uh that
he's open the open Overton window and
that needed doing and the consequence of
that would be that there would be more
hateful rhetoric there would be more
anti-c mights there would be more racist
and I'm I'm I'm perfectly happy with
that actually I don't problem blocking
people Etc um the thing that troubles me
much more more about what's happening on
social media is that um and Elon is
doing something about it with Community
notes and uh disincentivizing people
from posting fake content right but I I
quote tweeted a guy who since deleted
the Tweet only a few days ago who shared
a
video of American soldiers Landing in
Israel to go and fight oh and it I saw
that one and it turned out to be
completely F where was it it was from
well it was from 2002 in Romania yeah
and it was so obvious cuz even the the
military unit here CL it was was it was
clearly not them Etc but this is an
account with 1.5 million followers that
that video had been seen by tens and
probably millions of people um we have
to find a way particularly with the
coming of aih MH to be able to
differentiate between what's true and
what's not at least when it comes to
like videos in some ways does that seem
what the bigger problem is here now not
to finish anything that's happened there
or what's happening here but that we're
entering the sun County Valley with AI
now where we are so damn close to having
no idea whatever will be real including
guys that kind of are on the ball about
this stuff like us right right well
quite I mean you could we could get to a
point very soon where somebody could
take this and have us saying whatever
they wanted in any language in any
language right and we might not even be
able to see that or you know whatever so
that that's a big big problem in terms
of how we talk about what's happening
around the world uh but on Israel
Palestine I think we've seen exactly
what we've seen on every other issue is
people are so dumb that they will
automatically uh just follow the tribe
that they happen to be associated with
politically and not look at any of the
Nuance of what's going on and the people
who whose platforms get bigger and
bigger are the people who's who have the
lowest resolution take on all those
issues yeah let me ask you one thing
because the theme of this conference has
been telling a better story as someone
that you described yourself as an
optimist but you're obviously not
feeling particular ularly optimistic at
the moment I mean what's the story what
what's the missing line in the story
that would turn that around for you well
I gave a speech yesterday morning which
is uh already doing big numbers online
people can go and see that I I feel like
I I did a good job of laying out what
that might be um we just interviewed for
Neil Neil Ferguson the historian for
trigonometry and um you know he made the
point that if we were sitting here
exactly 50 years ago 1973 the last time
Israel was uh facing an invasion of of
of this scale and an atrocity of this
scale uh the picture wasn't just Bleak
in Israel it was also Bleak here in the
UK it was Bleak in America uh we have
recovered from things in the past uh
perhaps that I I like to think I'm a
smart guy but it doesn't mean I can see
the future perhaps there's something
coming that I haven't anticipated I'd
love to I'd love to hope that so you
think there's a chance there is always a
chance
yeah da good to see you again good to
see you man if you're looking for more
enlightening conversations about
international issues check out our
International playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell